Ms. Coffee Bean, what are you looking at?
Oh yeah, it is this new paper that took ViT,
scaled it up to 2 Billion parameters,
and ran it over 3 Billion images,
and casually set a new state-of-the-art on
ImageNet.
Why did they do this?
Because they can.
Because they Google.
But now we know.
Previously, there was always the question:
What would happen if we would go beyond the
300 Million images?
Well, this paper shows the scaling curve for
ViT up to the billions in terms of data and
parameters.
Showing that… the more data the better.
The more parameters, the better…
This scaling law for images, looks much like…
with GPT-3 for language.
But now we know, Ms. Coffee Bean.
Is your curiosity satisfied now?
Was it worth it?
[Sniff].
Ms. Coffee Bean, do you smell this?
Yeah, it smells like the best-paper award
for the next conference will ...